y américa latina en muchos países de la
región tiene el como sabemos altos
niveles de violencia desde desde hace
décadas no tienen contextos sociales
políticos complicados tienen también
altos niveles de impunidad que esto
viene a hacer más compleja todavía la
situación y por otro lado es cierto que
américa latina también se beneficia de
grupos de sociedad civil y grupos
indígenas y comunidades muy fuertes que
tienen una historial también muy
complejo y muy completo en demandar sus
derechos esto hace que muchas veces los
asesinatos sucedan precisamente porque
hay un reclamo no de estos derechos por
parte de estos derechos por parte de la
sociedad civil pero sí que es cierto que
muchas veces los defensores viven en
comunidades que se ven afectadas por
proyectos de desarrollo ya sean
proyectos forestales mineros
agroindustriales y albert que en esas
tierras donde ellos viven
llegan a estas tierras llegan proyectos
destructivos para ellas y para ellos o
para su comunidad alzan su voz y al
hacer esto se ven amenazados y muchas
veces por desgracia también asesinados